>>> THIS WEEK THE U.S. HIT AN
IMPORTANT MILE STONE.
HALF OF THE ADULT POPULATION IN
THIS COUNTRY IS NOW FULLY
VACCINATED AGAINST COVID-19.
YES, WE ARE BEATING THE VIRUS
BUT ON THIS MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND
THE COUNTRY IS FAR FROM HEALTHY.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC WE'VE
SUFFERED FROM A SERIOUS CASE OF
HERD STUPIDITY AS THE FAR RIGHT
WAGED A WAR AGAINST SCIENCE AND
IN SOME CASES AGAINST THE
SCIENTISTS LIKE DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI WHO PUT HIS FINGER ON A
BIG PART OF THE PROBLEM WE'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW.
>> THIS IS A WAR.
SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO FIGHT A
WAR YOU BETTER START SHOOTING AT
THE ENEMY INSTEAD OF AT EACH
OTHER.
I'M NERVOUS ABOUT THE INTENSITY
OF THE DIVISIVENESS IN THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
>> NERVOUS ABOUT THE INTENSITY
OF THE DIVISIVENESS.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI BATTLED A
PANDEMIC THAT'S KILLED NEARLY
6700,000 AMERICANS AND IN RETURN
HE HAS RECEIVED DEATH THREATS SO
SEVERE HE REQUIRED SECURITY FOR
HIMSELF AND HIS FAMILY.
THANKS TO PEOPLE LIKE FAUCI IT
IS SAFER TO GO OUTSIDE.
BUT HOLD ON.
NINE PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN SAN
JOSE, CALIFORNIA THIS PAST WEEK.
THE 232nd MASS SHOOTING IN 2021
ACCORDING TO THE GUN VIOLENCE
ARCHIVE.
SOMETIMES CHILDREN ARE THE
VICTIMS.
OTHER TIMES IT'S CO-WORKERS.
PEOPLE SHOT IN CLASSROOMS, AT
BIRTHDAY PARTIES.
WE CAN'T FIX THE PROBLEM BECAUSE
THE U.S. APPEARS TO BE
HOPELESSLY DIVIDED ON THE ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT CALLED THIS
EMBARRASSING AND IT IS.
>> EVERY SINGLE DAY, EVERY
SINGLE DAY THERE IS A MASS
SHOOTING IN THE UNITED STATES IF
YOU COUNT ALL OF THOSE KILLED
OUT ON THE STREETS OF OUR CITIES
AND OUR RURAL AREAS.
IT'S A NATIONAL EMBARRASSMENT
AND MUST COME TO AN END.
>> WE ALSO FACE AN OUTBREAK OF
HATRED, REPORTED HATE CRIMES
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS ARE UP
IN THE LARGEST U.S. CITIES.
THE ANTIDEFAMATION LEAGUE HAS
RECEIVED REPORTS OF HUNDREDS OF
INCIDENTS OF ANTI-SEMITISM THIS
MONTH ALONE.
CONSIDER WHAT ONE RABBI TOLD ME
LAST WEEKEND.
>> THIS IS NOT SIMPLY AN ERA OF
POLARIZATION BUT FANATICISM AND
THE RIGHT WING HAS MOVED TO THE
POINT, THE EXTREME RIGHT, THAT
IT NOW IS AKIN TO FACISM.
WE NEED TO DO MORE AND IT IS
TIME TO ACT NOT JUST SPEAK.
>> MEMORIAL DAY SHOULD BE A TIME
TO COME TOGETHER, TO REMEMBER
THOSE WHO DIED FIGHTING FOR THIS
NATION'S IDEALS.
YET AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IS AT
RISK AS THE BIG LIE IS STILL
DIVIDING THE COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO SOME RECENT POLLING
A MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS
BELIEVED DONALD TRUMP IS THE
TRUE PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
A SEPARATE POLL FOUND THAT
ONE-QUARTER OF REPUBLICANS P.
23%, AGREE WITH THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES LINKED TO THE QANON
MOVEMENT.
THE MAN WHO UNLEASHED THIS ERA
OF UNHINGED THINKING, FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP, IS NOW
BEING SHIELDED BY HIS PARTY.
THE SENATE DIOP BLOCKED AN
INDEPENDENT COMMISSION THAT
WOULD HAVE INVESTIGATED THE
INSURRECTION AT THE CAPITOL AND
HIS ROLE IN STOKING IT.
SOME IN THE GOP SOUND AS IF THE
REBELLION HASN'T ENDED.
>> WE HAVE A SECOND AMENDMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY AND I THINK WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO USE IT.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS ABOUT
MAINTAINING WITHIN THE CITIZENRY
THE ABILITY TO MAINTAIN AN ARMED
REBELLION AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT
IF THAT BECOMES NECESSARY.
I HOPE IT NEVER DOES.
>> HE HOPES IT NEVER DOES.
ARMED REBELLION.
YES, HE SAID ARMED REBELLION.
MATT GAETZ AND HIS PARTNER IN
SLIME MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
HAVE BEEN TRAVELING THE COUNTRY
AND INCITING THEIR CROWDS.
GREEN COMPARED MASK WEARING
REQUIREMENTS TO THE HOLOCAUST
AND LIKENED DEMOCRATS TO NAZIS.
>> YOU KNOW, NAZIS WERE THE
NATIONAL SOCIALIST PARTY JUST
LIKE THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOW A
NATIONAL SOCIALIST PARTY.
>> THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
SHAMEFUL.
BUT THERE WAS A TIME WHEN THE
WORLD CALLED ON AMERICA TO FIGHT
THE REAL NAZIS.
AND I CAN'T HELP BUT THINK ABOUT
ONE OF THE MOST MEMORABLE PLACES
I VISITED AS A WHITE HOUSE
REPORTER -- NORMANDY, FRANCE.
THOSE ARE MY PICTURES YOU'RE
LOOKING AT.
WHERE YOU CAN SEE ROW AFTER ROW
OF AMERICAN GRAVES MARKING THE
NEARLY 10,000 BRAVE HEROES WHO
ARE BURIED THERE.
I'LL NEVER FORGET WHAT I
WITNESSED ONE EVENING IN
NORMANDY.
I WAS AT A RESTAURANT AND I CAME
ACROSS THIS VETERAN OF THE WAR.
GATHERED AROUND HIM WERE ALL OF
THESE FOLKS LISTENING TO HIS
STORIES.
ABOUT THE WAR.
ABOUT WHAT HE AND HIS FRIENDS
WENT THROUGH ON THE BEACHES OF
NORMANDY TO DEFEAT THE NAZIS.
AND I CAN'T HELP BUT THINK WHAT
WOULD THAT GENTLEMAN AND HIS
FRIENDS THINK OF US RIGHT NOW?
WOULD THEY BE PROUD OF US?
WHAT WOULD THE GREATEST
GENERATION THAT DEFEATED THE
NAZIS THINK OF SEEING SWARMS OF
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS INVADING OUR
CAPITOL TO OVERTURN THE RESULTS
OF AN ELECTION?
WHAT WOULD THINK THEY THINK OF
THE COWARDICE ON DISPLAY THIS
WEEK IN THE SENATE?
ON THIS MEMORIAL DAY WHAT WOULD
THE GREATEST GENERATION THINK OF
US?
ARE WE THE WORST GENERATION?
WHAT WOULD THE GREATEST
GENERATION TELL US ABOUT THE
PERIL, THE DANGER, IN LOOKING
THE OTHER WAY WHEN THE FORCES OF
FANATICISM ARE ON THE RISE?
AND THEY ARE ON THE RISE IN
AMERICA.
SO, YES.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE WELL ON OUR
WAY TO BEATING COVID.
BUT MY F